[موسيقى]
السهل الممتنع فرقه المسرحيه تبني كل
مشاهدها بشكل ارتجالي تماما وتفاعلي مع
الجمهور فالجمهور هو جزء من العروض
المسرحيه الخاصه بهم نلتقي اليوم مع افراد
فرقه ارتجاليا تعرفت عليه في الجامعه
الامريكيه لما كنا لسه مسرح هناك انا
واخويا
ومن ساعتها بنعمل عروض ارتجال اللي هي
مبنيه على اقتراحات من الجمهور ما فيش اي
حاجه متحضره ما فيش اي حاجه متجهزه
الجمهور بيتفاعل معانا بنساله اسئله تحبوا
تشوفوا المشهد اللي جاي ده فين احيانا
بنطلب من الجمهور يطلع معانا على الاستيدج
في بعض
المشاهد
احيانا الجمهور مسموح يقول كلام عشوائي
جوه المشهد واحنا المفروض نستخدمه ونبرره
يعني بيصعبوها علينا
دلوقتي ايه هو الشيء ده
برط
مان ايه كمان
كنكه قهوه
ساجات مسمار مس حلاقه
[موسيقى]
يا لهوي ايه ده
ربنا كل حاجه علشان
لازم اتعلم ازاي اتخلى عن فكرتي العبقريه
وان انا افرض رايي لازم ابقى عندي
مساحه ان انا اسمع منك وابني على اللي انت
بتقوليه مش بس ابني على الافكار اللي عندي
انا فلازم ابقى ايجابي دي كلها حاجات
اساسيه جدا عشان اقدر اعمل معاكي مشهد
ارتجال لازم احنا كنا نبقى بنوافق على
افكار بعض لازم نبقى حابين افكار بعض حلو
والله
[موسيقى]
المسرح لما انا بدي لك نص فانت لازم تلتزم
بالنص اللي انت فيه ده ميه في الميه انا
محضره لك مفاجاه الارتجال بيعلم ازاي
ارتجل وافضل في نفس القصه بتاعتي واقدر
ازود عليها بناء يزود للقصه انا كنت شخص
اه يعني بعرف اتكلم
يعني عندي جراه ولكن الارتجال زود ثقتي في
نفسي جدا
في واحد طالب بره فاهيتا من غير فراخ
بتتعلمي تاخذي ريسك بتتعلميه تبقي دايما
ذهنك حاضر عارفه تقولي ايه
طبعا كل ده فني على البيرسني الليفل حتى
في التعامل مع البني ادمين في الحياه عامه
وفادني كممثله في في التمثيل نفسه وفيما
قبل بقى التمثيل اللي هو مثلا لو رايحه
اوديشن محمد اوعدني دلوقتي حالا ان ده مش
هيحصل لك مش هيحصل لك اوعدني ان انا
استشهد اوعدك
اوعدك اوعدني ان انا اول حد تعمل معاه كده